les conseillers départementaux étaient
réunis ce mercredi 28 octobre en séance
plénière dans l'hémicycle du palais de
la source
une séance plénière qui a permis le vote
du projet de mandature 2015 2021
parmi les grandes orientations trois
priorités ont été retenus
l'épanouissement humain le développement
territorial et l'intelligence
institutionnels nous avons au sein de
notre collectivité départementale une
politique ambitieuse un projet de
mandature ambitieux et nous voulons
travailler pour une cohésion à travers
l'action sociale à travers
l'accompagnement de nos enfants les
personnes âgées les familles le conseil
départemental qui poursuit ses efforts
dans le domaine de l'insertion avec
comme axes la formation des
bénéficiaires du revenu de solidarité
active à ménage sur trois sur quatre à
la réunion vit malheureusement du rsa et
que la politique de l'insertion est pour
nous une priorité des priorités et c'est
à dire essayer d'avoir un parcours
cohérent pour les bénéficiaires du crs
en avoir des formations adaptées des
formations qui répondent aux besoins des
entreprises bien sûr pour les
pour que ce public là puissent aller sur
un secteur marchand et aussi avoir des
formations au niveau d'être certainement
même des a saisi des chantiers
d'insertion eux mêmes le département en
met en place actuellement au sein de ces
structures
malgré un contexte très difficile et un
budget contraint les élus de la
collectivité met l'accent sur
l'accompagnement au quotidien des
réunionnais nous sommes des élus
départementaux
conscient des difficultés liés
évidemment aux restrictions budgétaires
mais nous sommes tellement motivés pour
faire en sorte de toujours répondre aux
besoins de la population réunionnaise
aux besoins de son quotidien aux besoins
de son avenir en nous en respectant bien
évidemment son identité sa culture sa
langue et nous allons l'accompagner dans
le champ de nos compétences comme je
vous le disais pendant ces six ans mais
avec une méthodologie qui est à mener de
façon conjointe est bien évidemment
porté par une présidente empreinte d'une
une identité réunionnaise comme personne
et est qui et qui nous porte d'une
motivation et d'un acharnement au
travail pour trouver effectivement les
bons moyens de répondre aux besoins de
la population réunionnaise lors de la
prochaine séance plénière les élus
débattront des orientations budgétaires
le vote du budget devrait suivre